ESPN radio color analyst he's on the
call for warriors rockets ESPN radio
tonight game four in Houston good
morning John hello Dan I heard about
your news the other day I hope you're
okay but I am I'm doing a whole lot
better and now you're calling where have
you been you could have called a couple
of days ago all of the other berries
called Ric and Brent called
oh yeah right all right Joe berry Carol
called okay let me start with Steph
Curry here is there is there something
else at play here he's that's three
consecutive games where Steph is not
Steph yeah
the looks are pretty good I got to think
something's going on with the left
sinker he seems to look at it all the
time shaking it I mean is four layups
the other night forget the dunk I mean
that that happens but a lot of a lot of
looks that I think I'm pretty good they
just aren't going in but at some point
don't you have to credit the Houston
Rockets how many people put him you know
have him struggle for three straight
games and he and klay Thompson certainly
a shadow of themselves shooting the
basketball both of them way clay is
about 40% the series and steps at 35 and
they got a battle on their hands tonight
it's gonna be very very interesting but
if you're looking and I thought Houston
was gonna win this series they should
have won Game one they didn't you know I
credit Golden State you know you win
these games sometimes you're not
supposed to and then Houston comes back
and and finally wins a game at home now
what is what is the chess match tonight
what changes because both teams are
gonna make adjustments certainly Golden
State will but what what's tonight's
game hinge on
well Houston flip the script certainly
on the rebounding they were smashed on
the bores in the first couple games
particularly offensive glass at that
second game Houston crafts the glass
they were they were more aggressive they
got the 50/50 balls I mean there's a lot
of ways you can look at this like using
Kevin Durant's going to get another 46
is that what it's going to take for
Golden State to be close doubtful is
Andre Iguodala going to continue to
shoot the ball at a 72% rate in the
series draymond greens at 65% now those
guys are getting opportunities that's by
design Winston because when you play the
lead for the Warriors any possession
that klay Thompson Steph Curry or Kevin
Durant don't shoot the ball I think
you've done a good job and I don't care
you know I don't think about layups or
dunks to get all green but if those guys
are shooting the ball you've done a good
job and right now
Iguodala and green are delivery and
they're getting 30 points again between
them each game and you have to live with
that and what happens is when those guys
make a couple shots a lot of people they
panic and they overreact and then they
go run at those guys and leave Klay open
or they leave stuff open and then the
floodgates open and the Warriors beat
you so Houston has to state discipline
continue their game plan and you know
James Harden he could be a little more
efficient I know he gets 41 but he
missed 18 of his 32 shots and I think a
little more Chris Paul he only took
eight shots and yeah four minutes you
know he think he could be a little more
aggressive feels like Chris Paul got old
overnight he's it is different yeah but
you know again James Harden has the ball
and you know Chris Paul for many years
he's played has had the ball in his
hands wherever he was and you know
that's not the case here in Houston
that's not the roly's plant talking to
John Berry the mothership he'll be on
the radio call tonight with warriors and
the Rockets that's at 9:30 Eastern the
Nuggets and the Blazers and Joe kitc
[Music]
I think when you watch you look at his
stats and you go god this guy must be
incredible and then you watch and you go
like he's like an old-school old man out
on the playground
how does he do it I mean I heard make a
lot of him killing I'm like what are you
kidding he should love this guy well he
loves him beat he's a big in bead fan
and I said look Joe Kitsch plays when in
bead plays then he's really good
but Joe Kitsch never stops playing yeah
I wish
Mbita at the heart of joke it does I
mean this guy goes sixty five minutes
the other night I didn't think he'd be
able to stand up last night and he goes
triple double again he reminds me a lot
of sabonis I think you mentioned that
name betta Sabonis he's a terrific
passer he's got seemingly very little
athletic ability but he's very smart
he's skilled I mean they run their
offense through the guy guys terrific
McLovin you want to respond to there's a
couple questions huh how many how many
titles did sabonis win and also do you
guys like Kukoc better than Jordan the
way I understand I'll reduce the bonus
by the way he come over when he was 19
20 years old he I was told even by
Michael Jordan that this guy would be
the second best player to him in the
league are we gonna give you know Saudi
votes won titles over Kobe and I'm Gasol
won that title over Kobe - Wow paulie's
feeling you know don't respond to him
John he's just trying to tag you on here
John's making me feel bad I don't feel
bad when I told him he's like I said hey
jock itch is young and he is
unbelievably talented and then you know
Nick Clements they go yeah but it's
another stat stuffing European Center
yes McClung well you have to understand
on all year Dan comes in my name or he's
like oh did you see Joe kitchen of the
weekend like he's the only one in
America that we know watching joke
come exhausting at the beginning of the
year I said Denver can go to the Western
Conference Finals and I thought well if
I'm going to say that I should at least
watch them since nobody else is and then
I would come in and then McLovin got
tired of hearing about Joe kitsch Larry
Bird I tell you I voted joke it's just
start today all-star game this year
okay I thought I thought he should have
been a starter well he's gonna be the
second he's gonna be second team All NBA
this year behind him bead I think so
yeah and he should be thank you said
that's a great year okay if the Raptors
don't beat the 76ers Kawhi Leonard is
going to dot dot dot
he's don't know the Clippers regardless
of what happens it's done I think okay
from all parties that I've been in
contact with I mean I'm no sniffer of
information but you're no one's yeah
alright so kawaiii is gone no matter
what happens here I believe so yeah okay
who's joining him there can they they
can get another match done yeah yeah Wow
I mean think about how great their
future looks with what they did this
year man you you a Kauai and then what
would you want
I like zoom box right I mean I don't
think I need another big I love their
young point guard Shea gilja's Allen
standard sham it is a nice to guard I
mean I don't know what they would need
who's out there that you want a bill to
he's kind of the same player as collide
you don't lean guy yeah what feels like
if they get Kawhi I love their future in
fact I I said this before I like the
Clippers future better than the Lakers
and an eyeball you know I had people
barking at me like how can you say that
the Lakers still have LeBron and I went
they don't have a coach yet by the way
do you think that Monty Williams turned
down the Lakers to coach the Phoenix
Suns no do you think no he wasn't
getting the job therefore he took the
Phoenix Suns job yeah I really don't
know I kind of surprised why would you
wait around a may TB sillies coach yes
they go out in this series I think that
Brad Brown could be in trouble
oh yeah I could see that but right I
mean when you want it I mean who would
you take Philly Phoenix or the Lakers it
depends if Phoenix gets his eye on then
I want to I want to coach Phoenix
well wait Phoenix is gonna take an eye
on you would you
no I'm serious if they get number one
job Iran to me is the guy for their team
they need a point guard and I like that
kid oh wow oh gosh so if you're one you
could say alright well we'll trade down
you know now I could get my guy John
Moran and I could get something else for
holding that number one pick if you were
the GM in Phoenix and you won the
lottery you're taking Joe Murr in um
yeah well I gotta sell my first round on
my first pick the ones I on the worst
for the most the Knicks I mean yeah okay
so that well there's nothing I wanna
sell the team and then I'll give you the
more thick for the betterment of the
league yeah that I didn't know if it
felt like tyloo was getting the Lakers
job but you know they brought in these
guys and interviewed Monty Williams and
Jason Kidd and but it's it's LeBron it
LeBron wants tyloo right of course I
understand yeah Jeff Van Gundy said
trade LeBron James I would do I would
tell what he said it to Longley agree
with it yes absolutely
yes absolutely if you said I can get
Anthony Davis for LeBron James right now
I would do that sure there's eight years
difference yeah I don't even need a
superstar to be quite honest with you
Oh take draft picks I would take you
know guys that I know can play I mean I
like a lot of the young town Brandon
England I hope he comes back if
everything's fine yeah I started I think
he's got a star potential
I like Kuzma no I like Alonzo ball I
mean maybe I'm in the minority there but
I think those days are gonna be pretty
good I felt the same way I thought this
was just a feeling out season let's just
let it play out see what we have take
inventory and then we'll hit the reset
button at the end of the year and of
course you know chaos ensued for the if
it could go worse it did with the Lakers
and now I just don't know what they have
and you know with LeBron moving forward
tyloo comes in is that is that a good
hire for the Lakers well it's good for
LeBron yeah but it's that good for the
Lakers I they have so many more pieces
that they have to put into this puzzle
to compete I mean obviously we don't
know what the Warriors are gonna look
like next year but can you say that the
Lakers are going to be a top four team
in the Western Conference next year
who's gonna go play with a bond I don't
I don't know what superstar that's gonna
be if it's gonna be any super story do
you believe what you know Durant and
Kauai sort of feel like you know it's
just a circus with LeBron and why would
you want to get involved with that yeah
I don't think either of those guys will
play with him I mean I could see a Jimmy
Butler I could see a Middleton I could
see maybe a DeMarcus Cousins but I don't
I just I don't think there's any thought
that Kevin Durant or Kawhi Leonard would
go play with that laughs do you think
that Kevin Durant can get to a point in
his career John where we recognize him
as being a better player than LeBron
historically oh I don't know
I think that's awfully tough I mean the
way he's playing right now obviously in
Kawhi or leaps and bounds above anybody
in the playoffs but
I don't know you know I mean LeBron has
been the chosen one for so long I mean
we've you know been watching this guy
since he was in high school you know and
I don't know you know
Durant he's a different player you know
he's not LeBron is a more well-rounded
player I thank to Kevin but certainly
there's things that Kevin does that no
one can do including LeBron did you read
Dennis Rodman's comments about LeBron
LeBron has no offensive moves and
meanwhile Jordan himself said I would
force LeBron laughs to shoot the jumper
which is no surprise and if he goes
right I can't stop him so he hasn't
moved
that's unstoppable according to the
greatest player in the history of the
game but Dennis Rodman feels like Scotty
is going to shut down Kevin Durant and
you know Michael shut down LeBron yeah
okay because Pippen is a wonderful
defensive player and usually when you
get to these arguments John you
denigrate somebody and I don't like
doing that but Scottie Pippen is not
shutting down Kevin Durant you know
somebody like that
yeah Dan especially in today's you can't
touch a guy yeah so like imagine what
Michael Jordan will be doing to this
league right now and the rules I mean in
the way the games played it's completely
different
I don't like to compare the errors you
know I mean like eating Bob Cousy could
get on the floor right now on anything
no I mean have you ever seen Seaton's
impersonation of Bob Cousy on the show
no it's so good it's just great are you
off channel 500 now on my DirecTV I'm on
audience now we're channel 239 o 230 ok
239 yeah yeah but yes never seen and he
just going right-handed the whole time
and somehow these defenders can't figure
out how about I force him to his left
it's and seaton will dribble around with
his head you know up and he's just
bouncing around with it it's you can't
stop Bob Cousy he's unbelievable he's a
magician on the floor you're going 40 to
his left oh my god
yeah don't try to throw it up there hey
great to talk to you about and have fun
tonight and we'll cross paths soon all
right be well thank you that's John
Barry ESPN Radio NBA color analyst he's
one of one of the people that I love
talking basketball to because he he
doesn't care from the standpoint he
doesn't play favorites you just talk
basketball with him and he's got this
historical background with his dad one
of the great players of all time his
brother playing with the Spurs he's just
a fascinating really interesting great
dinner partner you know the
conversations are always fun and he's
he's underrated you know being on ESPN
Radio used to do the pregame stuff with
me when we were on the mothership really
a lot of fun to be around he'll be on
the call tonight game four with the
Rockets and the Warriors four more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on VR
live or download the Dan Patrick show at